Tại sao tỉnh Wen mấy, chí thức công nghệ, đứa liệu, đời mới sáng tạo của chất lợn con người,
quyết định năng lịch, đẹp chanh của ra.
Đồng tư cho thách nhiên, tính là tổ tư cho năng lịch cảnh trang lâu dài, đất nước.
Một cuộc ra của phát triển nhân, quyền bướng, tự trù và hồi nhập thành công,
thì bỏ lớp thành nhiên, rồi chuyên môn, vũng ký năng, sáng vận quán,
bên mà lĩnh, của rời chất kẹp xa hội.
Hành nhiên không chỉ có học, để có bằng tấp mà phần học để làm người làm việc sáng tạo,
làm chủ của sống và phục sự tổ quốc.
Mối mạnh chàng, cả đến thành thoải quen từ học, lượt ngoại ngưu,
lẹn luyện, tí năng số, tí năng nghệ nghiệp, tươi rui phản biệt,
khả năng hợp tát, của năng lịch thích những người biết được nhé những hồi xa hội và thích chờ nấu đậu.
Tâm về củ vô, mạnh mẽ thình thành, thành nhiên, việc làm, làm chủ,
tươi, vận chí thích, vận lĩnh, của rời sáng tạo.
Tạo mùi trời người chẻ, hình kýu của học, khả nẹp sáng tạo,
lũng dục chí tệ nết tạo, phó chảy tình tế xanh, tình tế số, tình tế tò khoảng.
Bếp lỗi, thành nhiên, vui nhẹ trời,
việc hình kýu, thành nhiệp, trường ra, bị trời ngọt, và chí thức trẻ,
về năng tạo. Bệ giúp thành nhiên, biến lực mơ,
thành năng lực, biến năng lực, bị sản phẩm, biến sản phẩm, thành giá chị, cho đến nất.